[Music]  hand them over you can do without your  phones in one night how about reading a  book about heroes villains adventure  magic I would love to see real magic  within the walls of this mansion and  secrets are waiting to be uncovered  Scott I saw something up there and  worlds are about to collide  [Music]  I'm gonna hurt you  where do you come from a magical world  and sadly it's all gone our queen sent  us here on a quest to save my world  and stop its extinction but we will  follow here by an evil sorceress don't  you see when you say always world isn't  worth saving  wizards a sorceress  we need four elements to the stove I got  it Angelique oh really you're bringing a  knife to a wizard battle she's got a  point  we're rooting for you buddy  Adventures of Rufus the fantastic pet  watch this  you